I remember vividly at the dedication 20
years ago of the memorial there was a
World War one veteran in her uniform who
spoke she said when I served in the Navy
women were not even allowed to vote what
a brave woman so in that hundred years
that alone shows you where women started
in the military and everything is open
to them today there is nothing women
can't do at various times when I've been
here I've met women who served their
country and many times they would have
tears in their eyes because this is
hallowed ground for us
those of us at the foundation are
absolutely committed to the future of
this memorial and every day we get
reinforcements so to speak from our our
constituents military women themselves
most women who's served to include me
will never write a book about their
service they'll never be in anybody
else's book but they can record their
history by registering they can put the
picture a story of where they serve and
we want that to continue that's why
we're working so hard to sustain the
memorial this is an extraordinary place
and every day I learned that I learned
that we have to promote women and we
have to promote each other and to reach
out and make sure that this story is
told that for our kids
that my granddaughter knows that she can
do anything and that her brother knows
that she can do anything to
[Music]
you